Я хочу переконати світ у тому,
що українська компанія,
компанія з українським корінням,
може працювати, конкурувати і перемагати
на глобальних ринках з продукцією,
яку вона виготовляє.
Сніг, мороз, дощ, жарко.
«Іди погуляй зі мною!»
Тварина не скаже,
що їй щось не так, що їй щось болить,
що вона не має настрою і так далі.
І ти починаєш за нею слідкувати.
Починаєш переживати, які продукти дати їй їсти.
Починаєш слідкувати, чи ти правильно її годуєш,
чи ти правильний корм купуєш,
наскільки сильно вона виляє хвостиком.
Ми вважаємо себе сімейним бізнесом,
ми є друге покоління (я із сестрою
є друге покоління) нашого бізнесу,
бізнесової сім’ї Вовк.
І ми плануємо передати цей бізнес
нашим чотирьом донькам.
Це цікава річ, лапомийка для собак,
тому що в Україні міста не дуже чисті,
на вулицях не дуже чисто,
тож ми вирішили зробити такий,
назвали його «Pet shower».
Якщо люди хочуть, вони йдуть
і собачкам миють тут лапи.
Кормотех — це компанія,
у якій зараз працює 1000 працівників,
з яких 85 % є власниками котів,
або собак, або і кота, і собаки.
Кормотех — це лідер українського ринку.
Кормотех — це 61-та компанія світу за обсягами.
Кормотех наразі на наших
підприємствах виготовляє
приблизно 60 тисяч тонн готової продукції,
ще 20 тисяч має можливість замовити ззовні.
Ідея з’явилася 2000 року.
Ця ідея виникла в мого батька,
який заснував на початку 1990-х компанію,
яка виготовляла і наразі
виготовляє хлібопекарські дріжджі.
На початку двохтисячних вони відчули,
що ринок дріжджовий стагнує,
тому що люди менше
споживають хліба, і вирішили,
що потрібно диверсифікувати компанію
для стабільності тої компанії,
яка існувала, і для створення чогось нового.
Ідея була така: нам потрібно було знайти той ринок,
який росте в світі, і нам потрібно
було знайти той продукт,
який не виготовляється в Україні.
І ми хотіли виготовляти продукт
обов’язково з доданою вартістю,
високопрофесійний.
На цьому і зійшлись з ринком
корму для домашніх тварин.
Я персонально, і впевнений,
що вся команда мене підтримує,
хочемо змінити ставлення до тварин
зі сторони людей у східній Європі.
Ще один член команди і член сім’ї.
Його звати Хаус.
Це мій вест-хайленд-уайт-терьер.
Дев’ятирічна собака.
2001-й, 2003-й, до моменту створення Кормотеху, —
це було викристалізування ідеї,
пошук консультантів для покупки ноу-хау,
тому що на той момент в Україні навіть не знали,
як цей продукт виготовляти.
Ми зупинилися на американській
компанії, яка нам, станом на 2003 рік,
до початку старту заводу розробила
повністю всю бізнес-модель,
розробила всі рецептури і навчила наших працівників,
як виготовляти цей продукт.
Перше харчування, перші раціони,
вони були дуже гарні, кольорові.
Упаковка також розроблялася
компанією із світовим іменем,
і вони розробили упаковку
в дуже пастельних тонах,
дуже європейську, дуже англійську.
Й оце все пішло на ринок України.
Через пів року ми забрали всю продукцію назад,
тому що: а) люди наші
не сприймають кольорові гранули,
для них це хімія,
хоча там хімії ніякої не було,
і б) люди наші не люблять на полицях
супермаркетів пастельні кольори,
їм треба суперяскраві кольори.
Тепер ці рецептури були
повністю натурального кольору,
коричневого, як він і виходить з виробництва,
а упакування стало більш кольоровим.
Другий етап розвитку — це будівництво
фабрики з виробництва сухого корму.
Ми її закінчили в серпні 2005 року
і почали вже виготовляти наш продукт.
Фабрику ми запустили
з потужністю 30 тисяч тонн на рік,
тобто 2,5 тисяч тонн на місяць.
Дуже складний період нерозуміння продукту клієнтом.
Коли ми створювали, вибудовували дистрибуцію,
займали потрохи місця в зоомагазинах.
Нас не допускали в супермаркети,
бо були дві великі, і є,
мультинаціональні компанії,
які просто підписували такі контракти,
коли іншому виробнику туди
неможливо було потрапити,
тому ми працювали більше в зоомагазинах.
У 2008 році, я вважаю,
наступив переломний момент,
частково вплинула і допомогла нам криза.
Ми змогли певний час
пропонувати продукт дешевший,
ніж пропонували наші конкуренти.
Люди почали його пробувати і переконались,
що продукт високоякісний, що тварини їдять.
На жаль, ми відчули,
що українці так з острахом
ставляться до місцевого виробника,
а крім того, це є продукт, який завжди постачався чи з Європи,
чи зі Сполучених Штатів Америки.
Ми відкрили двері на фабрику
і почали показувати.
За декілька років провели
більше ніж 3 тисячі екскурсій,
вітали в себе ветеринарів, власників зоомагазинів,
звичайних клієнтів, великі мережі
супермаркетів, партнерів з Європи,
партнерів зі Штатів.
Зробили ми це на початку 2010 року.
Це також відкрило якусь
певну довіру до виробника
як для українців, так і для іноземців.
Наступним етапом ми збудували другу фабрику
з виробництва мокрих кормів, так званих паучів.
Це консервовані корми.
Далі, 2014 року, всі ми
пам’ятаємо і знаємо, війна.
Наш розворот на європейський вектор.
Ми зупинили співпрацю
з російським ринком і перейшли в Європу,
а далі, також 2014 року,
ми почали займатися соціальними проєктами.
Наших підопічних зазвичай на підприємстві
є близько сорока-п'ятдесяти.
Хто така собака?
Хто така собака, хто хоче іти гуляти?
У кожної собачки є карточка,
на якій є вся інформація:
звідки приїхали, який характер.
Ну що таке? Що таке?
В п'ятнадцятому році,
коли до нас звернувся
тодішній новоприбулий директор ЛКП,
він дзвонить і каже: «Слухай,
я прийшов на це підприємство,
ви львівська компанія,
ми —львівське підприємство».
Він каже: «У нас люди готують їжу,
ну тобто варять якісь каші з кістками
і так далі, це не збалансована їжа з одного боку,
з іншого боку, вони витрачають
дуже багато часу на це все,
допоможіть нам кормом».
І, фактично, з п'ятнадцятого року,
ми цю штуку організували,
і всі хвостики в ЛКП їдять наш корм,
відповідно, і працівники можуть
займатись іншою роботою,
більше турбуватися про хвостиків.
Одна з найголовніших
наших цінностей — це якість.
Ти не можеш зробити поганий продукт,
тому що собака або кіт
за одну секунду зрозуміє,
що цей продукт він не буде їсти.
Жоден продукт не виходить з нашої фабрики без того,
щоб ми не продегустували її з нашими тваринами.
Ми маємо в такому пулі дегустаторів:
200 собак і близько 150 котів.
Ми кожен продукт перевіряємо,
даємо на пробу тваринам, і якщо
нашому кінцевому клієнту це сподобалось,
то, значить, ми можемо спокійно виходити на ринок.
2015-й, напевно, рік — це запуск
нашого суперпреміального бренду.
Далі, на мою думку, невдалий старт
продажів у Сполучених Штатах Америки.
Ми прийшли туди, думаючи,
що там все буде так само, як у нас,
думаючи, що продукт, який є в нас,
спокійно може продаватися
в Сполучених Штатах Америки.
Все насправді не так.
Там клієнт потребує зовсім іншого,
там клієнт потребує інші рецептури,
інші сировини, інші назви
і там клієнт трошки інший загалом.
Звідси висновок, який ми для себе зробили,
потрібно ще раз.
Знову ж таки копіювання — ні.
Потрібно їхати на ринок,
потрібно вивчати клієнта,
потрібно спілкуватися з
партнерами, які потреби є в них,
які потреби ми можемо закрити,
які проблеми ми можемо закрити.
І зараз буде новий запуск.
Я впевнений, що він буде,
що він буде супервдалий.
Далі 2019–2020-ті  —
це побудова нової фабрики в Литві.
Повністю комп’ютеризованої,
роботизованої фабрики в Литовській республіці.
Завод у Литві будувався 9 місяців.
Я побував у Литві на заводі,
коли той уже почав працювати.
З української сторони у нас
займалася команда з чотирьох людей.
Дуже добре вдався вхід у Францію.
Ми в певних країнах працюємо
з так званими агентами,
які допомагають зв’язувати нас і клієнта.
Тобто це не дистриб’ютори,
це люди, які отримують відсоток
від підписаного контракту.
У Франції ми знайшли таку людину,
вона допомогла нам провести переговори
та домовитися з мережею садових центрів.
Ми були в тендері з бельгійцями,
і з французами.
Ми виграли цей тендер.
І почали працювати з виробництва,
знову ж таки, продукту
під власною торговою маркою мережі,
і зараз ми там вже продаємося більше ніж рік.
Ми задоволені, вони задоволені, ми постійно ростемо.
Цікава частинка нашого офісу.
Тут представлена карта світу,
на якій є помітки з місцями, де ми присутні.
Наприклад, зелений колір означає,
що ми в ту країну на цей момент експортуємо,
помаранчевий колір — та країна, де ведуться переговори з партнером,
де ми себе ще не відчуваємо,
або ще не зробили жодного постачання,
або хоча б одне постачання зробили.
Сірі країни — це ті країни, з якими
ми або тимчасово зупинили роботу,
або нам не вдалося, не знайшли партнера,
або партнер з нами розійшовся.
Останнє, коронавірусне,
коли минулого березня все зупинилось,
ми не змогли виїжджати за кордон,
ми почали, вся торгова
команда, всі комерсанти наші,
шукати партнерів,
які займаються онлайн-продажами,
тобто інтернет-магазини.
І ми знайшли в Норвегії великий,
найбільший інтернет-магазин,
який працює на скандинавському ринку,
котрий на той момент міняв свого партнера,
спочатку ми довго переконували,
що ми, українці, можемо це зробити.
Потім наша команда ветеринарів
переконувала і розповідала,
що таке наш продукт,
які його ключові переваги,
яка його концепція, які його цінності.
Та вже в травні ми продавалися
в цьому інтернет-магазині.
З 2021 року ми вже продаємось
у всіх скандинавських країнах,
навіть у магазинах їхніх партнерів.
Україна має величезний потенціал.
Ключове слово «має».
А не є вже, тому що
є певні перешкоди.
Але це величезний ринок, це величезна,
наголошую, європейська країна,
країна з європейськими цінностями.
Це країна, яка має дуже багато
розумних мізків, як це кажуть,
це країна, яка може створювати
високоякісні продукти,
та що найголовніше —
продукти з доданою вартістю,
не бути сировинним придатком,
а займатися переробленням.
Ти виростив зерно, ти до нього
щось додав, переробив,
ще раз додав, ще щось переробив.
На цьому будується маржа,
на цьому будується прибуток,
на цьому будується майбутнє будь-яких країн.
Росте ВВП, всі люди починають ставати багатшими,
вони ж тратять більше грошей
на покупки й так далі.
Коли до тебе приїжджають партнери,
величезні світові виробники,
коли ти на виставках зустрічаєшся
з партнерами зі світу,
хоч як пафосно це звучить,
але ти потрошки підіймаєш цей бренд України,
який дуже потребує цього підняття.
Тому це дуже важливо для мене.
Ну і це в наші місії написано:
ми виготовляємо доступне
та високоякісне харчування для тварин,
щоб дарувати радість їхнім власникам
від спілкування з життєрадісною і здоровою твариною.
Це те, що ми робимо,
це наш основний напрям бізнесу.